[Music]
now my pleasure to introduce our
commencement speaker dr. Ben s Bernanke
the 14th chairman of the Federal Reserve
dr. Bernanke is an illustrious graduate
of MIT having received his PhD in
economics in 1979 ladies and gentlemen
distinguished guests graduates parents
and graduates to be dr. Bernanke good
morning president Hockfield members of
the faculty alumni families and friends
of graduates and especially members of
the 2006 graduating class I'm honored to
speak at the hundred and fortieth
commencement exercises of this
distinguished institution it's wonderful
to be back at MIT I graduated from the
Institute with a PhD in economics in
1979 that year president Wiesner gave
the commencement address
he spoke about among other things the
nation's transition from an era of cheap
energy to one of energy scarcity and the
need for new technologies to aid in that
transition obviously these issues still
confront us and one can't help but
wonder whether that theme will feel as
current 27 years from now as it does
today as for today you may have been
surprised to learn at some point that an
economist rather than an engineer or a
scientist would be serving as your
commencement speaker but in my remarks I
hope to illustrate that this address
continues a long and productive
tradition of collaboration at MIT
between economics and the engineering
and scientific discipline
building on that theme I like to discuss
the essential complementarity of
Technology and economics in modern
economies and finally I'd like to have a
few words with you as MIT graduates
about what you can do to strengthen our
economy and our society even as you
pursue your personal and professional
goals if you'll bear with me I'd like to
begin with a short history of economics
at MIT the MIT Economics Department is
of course the part of the Institute that
I know best and I hope to persuade you
that it has played a unique and special
role in this institution mi t--'s
connection to economics States at least
back to 1881 when Francis a walker
became the institution's third president
to say that Walker had already had a
distinguished career would be an
understatement he was named a brevet
Brigadier General at the end of the
Civil War at the age of 24 he served as
a superintendent of the 1870 and 1880
decennial censuses of the United States
and was one of the leading economists of
his era the year he arrived at MIT he
taught the first economics course ever
offered at the Institute the course
covered political economy and was so
popular that it was soon accorded its
own course classification as course nine
general studies Walker helped found the
American Economic Association which is
still the leading professional
association for economists and during
his tenure at MIT he moonlighted both as
the first president of that Association
and as president of the American
Statistical Association in the early
20th century the economics program at
MIT aimed to prepare undergraduates for
leadership roles in business during
those years economics as a discipline
gained greater prominence both here and
abroad but the modern era of economics
at MIT began in 1940 the year that
Paul's
Amonson not yet having even received his
doctorate was persuaded to emigrate here
from a somewhat less technically
proficient institution on another
stretch of the Charles River in part
Samuelson was willing to leave Harvard
because his foundations of economic
analysis a book now universally regarded
by economists as inaugurating the modern
mathematical approach to economics was
not well-received by the old guard at
the Harvard Economics Department mi
t--'s PhD program in economics was
established a year after samisen arrived
and right from the start the department
attracted strong graduate students the
very first of these Lawrence Klein
receives a Nobel Prize for economics in
1980 for his work in econometrics
modelling with support from MIT
administration the department expanded
rapidly after World War two and MIT led
the development of a more mathematically
rigorous approach to economics given the
emphasis on quantitative reasoning at
MIT it makes perfect sense that the
economics department here was in the
vanguard of those using mathematics as a
framework for organizing economic
thought these developments laid the
foundation for economics as a discipline
in the second half of the 20th century
and the department quickly rose to the
top of national rankings besides
Samuelson many economists contributed to
the department's outstanding reputation
Franco Modigliani Robert Solow
Charles Kindleberger rüdiger thornbush
and Stanley Fischer to name just a few
particular Ani Samuelson and solo all
won Nobel prizes for their research and
in addition nine other economists with
MIT connections have won nobels
the MIT Economics Department has trained
many economists who have played leading
roles in government and in the private
sector including the heads of four
central bank's those of Chile Israel
Italy and I might add the
it states one of my teachers at MIT Stan
Fischer is a sterling example of what
MIT training can produce stand followed
the brilliant career as a researcher and
a teacher at MIT with important work as
a public servant including top positions
at the World Bank the International
Monetary Fund and currently the Bank of
Israel why did economics at MIT become
so successful
perhaps Paul Samuelson and the people he
helped to attract here could have been
equally successful anywhere but I
suspect that the placement of economics
in a milieu where quantitative reasoning
and the scientific method where the coin
of the realm was an important
contributing factor the Sloan School
with its close links both to the
economic department and to other parts
of the Institute has benefited from the
same new year and has been the source of
many fort important fundamental advances
as well notably in recent years the
global financial industry has been
transformed by quantitative approaches
to pricing complex financial instruments
such as derivatives and the measuring
and management of risk
this transformation stemmed from the
application of formal tools of
mathematical economics that were
developed to a substantial extent by the
faculty at the Sloan School including
Fischer black Robert Merton
and Myron Scholes the latter two of whom
won Nobel prizes for their work as MIT
economics has benefited from its
proximity to the scientific and
engineering expertise of MIT so the
Institute has benefited from the
presence of a world-class economics
department over and above the addition
of still more lustre to the MIT name the
exposure of students and faculty from
other disciplines to economics has
stimulated creative thinking about how
technology can be used to improve the
economic welfare of the average person
that thought brings me to my second
topic which is the link between
technology and
genomic growth as has always been the
case
technological change and innovation are
today in large part driving economic
growth and the improvement of living
standards but it's important to
understand that even the very best ideas
and science or engineering do not
automatically translate into broader
economic prosperity in large measure the
material benefits of innovation spring
from complementarities between
technology and economics where I include
in economics not only economic ideas but
also economic policies and even the
entire economic system when the
economics is right scientific and
technological advances promote economic
development which in turn in a virtuous
circle may provide resources and
incentives to help foster more
innovation a negative example is the
former Soviet Union which certainly did
not lack for scientific and engineering
talent but which had an economic system
that was poorly suited for translating
scientific advances into economic
progress the experience of the United
States over the past decade illustrates
the essential complementarity of
Technology and economics before the
mid-1990s the growth of productivity the
amount of output produced per worker or
per hour of work had been relatively
sluggish for more than two decades in
this country as productivity is perhaps
the single most important determinant of
average living standards a country in
which an average worker can produce a
lot is also typically a country in which
an average consumer can consume a lot
the so called productivity slowdown of
that earlier period was the source of
much concern on the part of economists
and policymakers the growth rate of
productivity increased and picked up in
the mid 90s in the United States and
increased still further around the turn
of the century and it remains strong
today this productivity revival augers
very
well for the future of the US economy
but why did it happen you graduates of
all people will not be surprised to hear
that research suggests that the pickup
in US productivity growth in the
mid-1990s was importantly related to
advances in information and
communication technologies but these
technical advances in and of themselves
can't be the whole story
for example even though the new
technologies are widely available around
the world many other countries appear
not to have derived the same benefit as
has the United States notably
productivity in Europe which increased
rapidly in the decades after World War
two but then decelerated in the mid
1990s about the same time that US
productivity growth picked up thus the
gap between the productivity levels in
the United States and Europe which had
nearly closed by 1995 have been widening
what accounts for the apparent
differences in the effects of technology
here and abroad differences in economic
policies and systems likely account for
some of the differences in performance
another example of the complementarity
of Technology in economics one leading
explanation for strong US productivity
performance is that labor and product
markets in the United States tend to be
more flexible and competitive and that
these market characteristics have
allowed the United States to realize
greater economic benefits from new
technologies for example taking full
advantage of new information and
communication technologies may require
extensive reorganization of work
practices reassignment and Retraining of
workers and ultimately some reallocation
of labor among firms and industries
regulations that raise the cost of
hiring and firing workers and the reduce
the ability of firms to change work
assignments like those in a number of
European countries may make such changes
more difficult to achieve
likewise in product markets a high
degree of competition
and low barriers to entry of new firms
in most industries in the United States
provides strong incentives for firms to
find ways to cut costs and to improve
their products competition is one of the
key benefits of a free and open trade
and companies that are exposed to global
competition tend to be more efficient
and produce goods of higher quality than
companies that are sheltered from
international competition other economic
factors have probably been important in
translating technological change into
material progress some observers point
to the depth liquidity and
sophistication of American financial
markets as contributing to recent
productivity gains sizable markets for
venture capital and ready access to
equity financing facilitate start-up
enterprises which are often the best
means of bringing new technologies to
market the United States also benefits
from its high quality research
universities which have shown both the
willingness and the ability to
collaborate with the private sector and
in some cases with the government as
well in the development and
commercialization of new ideas for
example Intel was co-founded by an MIT
graduate and MIT graduates have played
key roles in designing and developing
the Internet one interesting feature of
us and global experience with major
innovations is that often a significant
amount of time passes between the
initial development and diffusion of new
technologies and the realization of the
Associated productivity benefits
computers were first commercialized in
the 1950s for example and personal
computers came into widespread use in
the early 1980s but until the mid-1990s
these developments had little evident
effect on measures of productivity
indeed mi t--'s Robert Solow famously
said in 1987 that computers are
everywhere except in the productivity
statistics moreover despite the sharp -
and information technology investment
after the meltdown of high tech high
tech high sector stocks earlier this
decade the growth rate of productivity
has actually increased in recent years
as I mentioned these long legs raise
additional questions about the nature of
the links between new technologies and
the resulting productivity gains perhaps
the answer lies in taking the longer
view some research by economists has
drawn an analogy between modern
information and communication
technologies and earlier so-called
general-purpose technologies such as the
steam engine the electric motor and the
internal combustion engine
general-purpose technologies have broad
application and thus have the potential
both to revolutionize methods of
production and to make a host of new
goods and services available to
businesses and consumers for example
when smaller electric motors replace
single power sources such as steam or
water power in manufacturing facilities
it became feasible to reorganize the
layouts of plants to optimize the flow
of materials rather than the
distribution of power and the advent of
air conditioning significantly expanded
opportunities for economic development
in the warmer regions of the United
States and the rest of the world however
in all these cases developments evolved
over a long period and required firms to
make collateral investments in research
and development organizational structure
and employee training these investments
in learning how to make the best use of
new technologies have been dubbed
intangible capital to distinguish them
from investments in physical goods like
new equipment and machines in the case
of information and communication
technologies new economic research
suggests that the investments in the
associated intangible capital that means
figuring out what to do with the
computer once it's out of the box are
quite important in my view important
investments in intangible capital remain
to be made
as much still remains to be learned
about how to harness these technologies
most effectively as graduates of MIT you
will be at the heart of this critical
process of developing new technologies
and in some cases taking them to the
marketplace we are in an age in which
technology and its fruits will be a
dominant force not only in our economic
lives but in the cultural social
political and personal aspects of our
lives as well your training at MIT
equips each of you exceptionally well to
take the fullest advantage of the
professional and personal opportunities
the technological innovation and change
will create each of you because of your
youth your talent your demonstrated
commitment to learning and your personal
and intellectual achievements during
your time at MIT we'll soon find to
paraphrase Shakespeare that the world is
your oyster I hope that you will
contribute in some measure to economic
progress whether in the United States or
elsewhere and I hope you find some
measure of financial reward but the
world has a great deal more to offer
than money and a key question each of
you will face repeatedly in your lives
is how to use the talent and education
that you've been given and the knowledge
that you have attained with respect to
your professional lives I hope that when
you make career choices you will look
first for opportunities that excite you
intellectually that allow you to use
your creative powers to the fullest
extent and that lets you continue to
learn and grow I hope you will not be
afraid to be unconventional to do
something that nobody else has thought
of before and remember that the path to
success and fulfillment may well not be
well marked the scaling of some
predetermined ladder it may instead be a
road without signs and without maps and
remember it's okay to fail really new
opportunities will always arise for
those
and if you remain nimble and searching
out new and unexpected opportunities it
will not only benefit you but it will
also benefit the economy and the society
because long experience has shown that
dynamism and creativity are the seeds of
innovation and of progress in the
personal sphere as you make your way in
the world I hope you will not forget the
importance of your family and how much
it has already contributed to your
journey through life
remember to family members are the ones
who are going to still love you even
when things aren't going so well and
even as you focus intensively on your
professional interests I hope you will
remain intellectually broad well-read
well-informed and open to new
experiences and finally I hope you will
remain engaged with the broader society
that may involve entering public service
at some point as many MIT graduates have
chosen to do but it did not there are
always opportunities to make a
difference in the world through
volunteering civic participation
charitable activities or just the nature
of the work that you choose to do I
congratulate all the graduates and your
families for what you have accomplished
and then the end by wishing you the very
very best for the future thank you very
much
you